Good morning John; it's Wednesday, January
17th.
Hi Maureen Johnson and E. Lockhart! Maureen...
is that the Maureen that told me to build
a business card house out of my misprinted
business cards? If it is, then I have a surprise
for her! Last night, I spent two hours talking
to a libertarian on the internet. He was a
friend of mine from high school and I don't
know what happened. He says there shouldn't
be regulations on nuclear power plants!
Last night, I also blew my nose for fifteen
straight minutes, and then at the end of it,
I had converted six ounces of toilet paper
into two pounds of mushy goo, but now I can
do this! (breathes in through nose deeply)
Ahhh.
I'm just going to jump right into Misprinted
Business Card Utilization ideas. Maureen from
the comments suggested that I build a business
card house. I didn't know how to build card
houses, so I went on the internet and did
some research. There's the basic card house,
where you use, you know, this and this and
then you stack until it gets high up, but
that's not the best way to build card houses
it turns out. I found out the way that the
professional card stackers do it. And now,
I'm going to teach you and all of our viewers
how to stack cards, the awesome way!
We create a T. And we lean this card on this
card, thus stabilizing this card and this
card.
Is that guy wearing jammie pants?
And this guy on this guy.
Yes, that guy is wearing jammie pants! It's
early and I'm sick and tired, okay?
And you lean this guy on that guy, then you
lean this guy on that guy. Here we've got
the first story of a really good card house.
And now we add the roof; this is important
because we're going to be stacking more stories
on it. Oh. And... Voilà! And there we have
the first story of a card house.
(unintelligible squeaky sped up voice)
Let us take a look at this thing of beauty.
An excellent Misprinted Business Card Utilization
idea; especially because now I know how to
stack cards! And hopefully, so do you.
So, I can't just let this go; I'm going to
have to try and add another story.
(squeaky voice chatters, exclaims)